[Musique]
salut les amis voici une petite surprise
de Noël pas de podcast mais un best of
vrai compil des meilleurs moments de
notre draft 2017 chez envergure à
l'époque je crois que ça plaît même pas
envergure on avait fait un live de 5h
pendant la draft et voilà donc quelques
minutes de compil de très très mauvais
stake franchement pas mal de textes
catastrophique qu'on a progressé
heureusement depuis mais heureusement il
y a aussi dans ce live des prédictions
que peu de gens avaient fait à l'époque
par exemple sur Donovan Mitchell on
avait un son tout à fait horrible mais
on avait vibré voilà pour cette draft
qui s'est avéré très surprenant vous
allez entendre des voix de Ben de Manu
vous entendez encore c'était la première
de Romain avec nous on avait également
Antoine qui annonçait avant même Twitter
les choix qu'il avait qu'il avait parce
qu'il avait les infos de Jonathan giveni
à l'époque et puis vous allez entendre
un certain Kevin hanstep qui est
maintenant GM de Limoges un certain Alex
Biger staff que vous entendez sur RMC et
puis des auditeurs fidèles par exemple
notre fan deskins préférés Nico enfin
voilà tout ce que vous allez trouver
vous de quoi vous remémorer cette soirée
du trade de Jimmy Butler et ouais
l'époque des faux compte vos genarovski
sur Twitter et oui l'époque New York
Hurley sa joie d'avoir drafté Franck
mini Kina bref c'est Noël c'est notre
montage cadeau et avant ça et avant ça
une annonce à vous faire un vrai cadeau
pour le coup pour un de nos auditeurs on
a été contacté par sa petite amie pour
un cadeau de Noël alors elle voulait
qu'on organise une rencontre entre donc
son mec et des membres de chez nous de
notre podcast et bien ce sera fait on a
trouvé à peu près une date fin janvier
un match à Lorient Lorient contre le
Pôle France donc c'est de la
nationale une et cette auditeur fidèle
va rencontrer certains membres pas tous
On n'est pas tous ceux dans la même zone
géographique mais certains membres de
notre équipe franchement ça nous fait
presque plus plaisir qu'à lui et donc on
dévoile ce soir c'était prévu ainsi par
sa meuf et moi son pseudo il s'appelle
shostigal sa copine c'est Lisa merci à
toi justigal d'écouter nos podcasts on a
vraiment hâte de te rencontrer merci à
Lisa d'être aussi Mims franchement si
vous m'avez dit un jour que ce serait un
cadeau que des gens d'envergure
rencontrent des auditeurs j'aurais souri
sans trop y croire et merci donc on
donne rendez-vous à Lorient évidemment
ce stigal et merci à vous tous à tous
les autres de nous écouter passer de
bonnes fêtes je vous laisse avec donc le
best of de la draft 2017 en live à
l'époque c'était sur le site c'était
hébergé sur le site de basket session je
vous fais des bisous à tout le monde à
l'équipe de Rivers aussi d'ailleurs
bisous tout le monde ciao ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et des pics ouais
c'est vrai c'est comme aller chez
McDonald's
on rappelle que
dites-moi les gars est-ce que l'homme
avec le meilleur nom au monde Axel
bouteille va être raté cette année ce
qui sera le théâtre
non je pense pas
pourquoi mais pourquoi je connais rien
sur lui
c'est pas possible
il a
le meilleur nom de la merde dans le
joueur de basket
on ne touche pas avec cette
ille pour Benoît un poste 3 mes petits
pour un 3 en NBA il est à 6ix je crois
mais
enfin offensivement il est talentueux un
bon shooter capable de là sur les
finales il est pas mal contre Strasbourg
et l'année prochaine il a déjà signal
Limoges en plus
mais il manque enfin cruellement de
rapidité d'explosivité d'un point de vue
NBA pour espérer drafté ou enfin même au
second tour peut-être une équipe tu sais
en fin de second tour qui veut juste un
nom histoire de draftenstache Why Not
messieurs je vous propose d'accueillir
Thibault c'est maçonnette invité
les moyens sont lourds les moyens sont
lourds
merci merci de reconnaître
tout à fait Tibo salut bonsoir à vous
Thibault qui est fan des 6h
qui qui va réagir puisque on sait depuis
une bonne trentaine de minutes depuis
ouais c'est ça 30 minutes
on n'est pas en live en live télévision
on sait que Marcel c'est pas une
surprise du tout va être drafté quel est
ton sentiment
en sentiment personnel c'est que je suis
absolument extatique ravie du choix
ravie du trade qui conduit à la
possibilité de ce choix là
l'échange de l'échange de Jimmy Butler
au word du ministre complété ok on
laisse finir avec
oh non c'est plus intéressant
quand il sera complété
[Musique]
j'ai jamais vu un chantier aussi long de
toute ma vie donc
il est temps que ça il est temps que ça
aboutisse à quelque chose et folk c'est
une sacrée assurance voilà pour tout ce
qui a été mis en place jusqu'ici et puis
marquer le fait qui exhibent des très
belles chaussures faites en ballon de
basket c'est aussi la défaite du mauvais
goût les soirs de draft pour devenir
je suis en live avec Jonathan là
il peut vous les enfiler à trois points
je les trouvais pas assez présent dans
le secteur intérieur justement chez les
Blue des vols mais
pour un gars après voilà entre Titom et
Jackson le plus score des deux ça sera à
tous les coups titum le plus près pour
la NBA point d'interrogation si je
penche vers Ajax
est fait Jimmy Butler ça va ça va à
Minnesota contre Zach Lavigne Chris down
et le choix numéro 7 au total je peux
pas croire qu'ils préfèrent avoir ce
package là que d'avoir n'importe quoi
que les que les sortes puissent proposer
bon c'est magnifique pour pour Minnesota
sont engagés dans des sérieux la
discussion sur Paul George
[Musique]
Jackson c'est officiel c'est un
excellent choix pour Phoenix
George Jackson va devenir une Valette
avec cette équipe notre ami rose compare
Joe Jackson à la c'est le meilleur
comparaison
pour une fois je suis d'accord parce que
je te cache pas que les deux premiers
c'était n'importe quoi
[Musique]
qu'il devienne un meilleur shooter
défensivement aussi
basket c'est très très haut il dit je
trouve
et n'hésite pas à parler fort en tentant
de loin
ouais Nico Jarron Fox pour l'instant tu
es content mais qui ne sont pas fait de
bêtises pour l'instant ça va mais c'est
dur de bêtises enceinte
et si vite arrivé
exactement
je suis content d'avoir Fox parce que ça
fait depuis macby et benaudry qu'on a
pas un vrai meneur
[Rires]
tristesse incroyable ce que tu me dises
je pense hein
la seule chose qui fait c'est poster ses
stats à chaque fois
47 points 17 rebond 8 à 7
Peyton
paresseuse dont je suis pas d'accord
avec une comparaison capillaire mais moi
aussi le remarques avec le pied numéro 7
OK
c'est annoncé à Orlando et il est très
long et athlétique comme j'en avais les
hommes mais je me pose la question à
Orlando du feat avec Iron Gordon
et et vous de ceviche le site est
magnifique
je te sens sarcastique un peu Antoine
je suis quand même dubitatif sur Isaac
capable de jouer trois immédiatement à
NBA
c'était une blague ou pas
ils ont listé tous les meneurs qu'on
Chicago et le pourcentage
le pourcentage
vient de changer sa photo aussi photo de
profil et cover sur Twitter avec Zac
Lavigne et tout et je crois qu'il va pas
tarder à toutes et il y a la cmdouls qui
me je suis en contact avec elle parce
que j'ai eu la chance d'aller là-bas
ils étaient pas du tout prêt à ça avec
que fais-tu Benoît que fais-tu tu t'es
laissé devant
et ben
parce qu'il y a rien chez moi
de l'histoire en français je respire le
moment les gars je respire le moment
sur la scène mettre la casquette de NX
et pour un moment m'imaginer que fait le
Jackson n'est pas président il y a des
sifflets ou pas
non non
[Musique]
il a fallu
on a on a notre meneur du futur
maintenant il faut quand je dis il fait
du action allez les gars Antoine Denis
Smith Dallas bon feat
j'aurais tendance à dire du coup que
c'est pas un bon film pour Dallas je
pense que c'est vraiment pas le meneur
qui espérait on en a quand même vu
passer 5 déjà quoi c'est énorme
mais melon quand même pris je pense que
par contre c'est un
c'est la meilleure option possible pour
Dennis Miss lui-même c'est un mec qui a
besoin de travailler c'est un mec qui a
besoin de d'avoir un coach qui va leur
mettre à sa place la comparaison a été
exceptionnelle
Charlotte annonce que Malik mank va être
leur choix avec le 11e choix au total ce
qui fait beaucoup de sens et c'est pas
mal pour c'est pas mal pour Charlotte ça
c'est bien pour Charlotte et pas de Wake
for eyes de You & See ou de dudukes
donc du coup à l'espace ça veut dire que
Mitchell supposément slide de Ré la vare
a commencé il a dit lonzo vous va
emmener les cœurs sur playoffs dès sa
première saison il avait déjà dit ça
[Applaudissements]
comment il fait comment il pousse ça
j'en ai aucune idée Antoine a toutes les
infos en avance depuis généralement un
quart d'heure avant nous et il était pas
au courant
donc
ça va tu es là il est bon là je suis pas
fan du trade perso pour Denver vas-y
explique
je sais pas il
descendent quoi 11 places
pour très live
je vous avoue j'aime pas trop non plus
pour être
ça très bien par contre ouais
je suis dans la team style j'étais
obligé de faire cul sec sur ce sur cette
il a montré
notamment workout je sais pas si vous
avez vu les vidéos de workout si vous
avez pas vu si vous nous écoutez allez
les voir qui savait shooter beaucoup
plus que ce qu'il avait montré cette
année on va dire à Louise mais après
c'est aussi parce que Louisville c'est
une équipe qui cache beaucoup ses
joueurs offensivement à défensivement il
y a beaucoup de systèmes et qu'on se
demande Michel je pense que c'est
un des joueurs qui a le plus de
potentiel à long terme sur cette droite
oh les gars
le hit va sélectionner Bamada avec le
14ème
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis
très doué
ça va être épique en Floride
par rapport à ce que tu es disponible
encore là derrière enfin pour moi
Justine battle et encore même jarretalen
c'est c'est mille fois mieux quoi les
box vraiment voulaient pas mal de Bayo
en numéro 17 et que selon Rory essaye
d'un autre et espiènes à des bailleurs
et projeter pour comme étant le
Tristan Thompson des pauvres qu'en
pensez-vous
qui dit de la merde
[Musique]
je suis très souple et jelly qui a été
choisi avant Audi and only il doit y
avoir quelque chose avec la blessure
doit être parce que on rappelle qu'il
est pas dispo avant un bon moment
c'est un excellent choix des rapports
[Rires]
quelques secondes on aime bien les gars
non
stretching en backup moi j'aime bien
quelques
quoi les cœurs
42 c'est ouf je savais que tu avais
mais alors à ce point là c'est
probablement une mise à jour sur sur
Jeff Wetter que le dont je suis
absolument profane mais
ça dépend
si tu joues
au volley-ball
considérer le joueur le plus intelligent
de l'adresse
et ben voilà il est content